pierre laurent journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de la russie qui est avec
nous sur ce plateau monsieur laurin
bienvenus merci merci d'être avec nous
alors on va parler des enjeux de cette
rencontre bien évidemment mais juste
avant peut-être vous parler de la
position turon c'est moscou était clair
depuis le début elle soutient l'armée de
bachar el assad dans ce conflit syrien
les turcs soutiennent qu'ils alors les
turcs eux c'est très difficile à dire
qu'ils soutiennent en tout cas ce que
l'on peut dire c'est que avant tout ils
soutiennent leurs propres politiques
leur propre politique c'est d'essayer de
créer dans l'hypothèse d'un démembrement
de la syrie qui était tout à fait
possible
il ya encore deux ans d'essayer de créer
une enclave pro turc eux autour d'idleb
c'était en gros la stratégie qui était
mise en place par air de ram et qui
semblait être atteignable il y avait
réellement une possibilité que la
turquie ait réussi simplement parce que
l'armée syrienne n'était pas encore
n'avait pas encore la dynamique de
reconquête qu'elle a eu par la suite
parce que les tur penser que les russes
eux iraient très doucement dans les
attaques éventuelles contre des zones où
pouvait se situer des soldats turcs et
puis sont arrivés les accords de sotchi
et là il n'y avait plus de possibilités
pour air douanes de d'échapper à aux
règles qu'il avait lui-même fixé
c'est-à-dire la région d'idleb doit être
libéré les troupes turques peuvent
stationner dans une bande relativement
étroites tout le long de la frontière
elles ont reçu quasiment le feu vert
pour attaquer les kurdes ce qu'elles ont
fait ça allait au delà des accords de
sotchi mais bon
c'était le prix à payer 10 ans pour
avoir la collaboration des turcs et la
voilà que soudain alors que l'offensive
syrienne est engagée que les séries 1
combattent des groupes djihadistes
essentiellement jihadistes dans la
région d'idleb
on apprend que des soldats turcs sont
morts et ce qui s'est passé justement
vous parlez d'une vous parlez d'une
dynamique de reconquête poli de l'armée
syrienne on a pu constater justement
maintenant actuellement on a les turcs
qui bombarde l'armée syrienne qu'est ce
qui s'est passé entre l'accord de sotchi
qui prévoyait une zone des mythes à des
réseaux dans la danse en provence est
maintenant bien ce qui s'est passé c'est
simplement que l'opération de reconquête
syrienne s'est heurtée aux intérêts
turcs les turcs n'étaient pas préparés à
céder du terrain
il pensait qu' il pouvait continuer à
être dans la pénombre
or il aurait pu rester dans la pénombre
il y a eu une trentaine ont 10 33
soldats turcs qui ont été tués par des
frappes syrienne ça aurait pu passer
pour un accident si les turcs avaient
dire que c'est un accident il était là
pour des raisons humanitaires ou peu
importe il n'y aurait pas eu l' escalade
qu'il ya eu par la suite
et à partir du moment où ils disent ça a
été un acte de guerre
eh bien le peuple turc crient vengeance
dont qui sont obligés à doan s'est
sentie obligée d'engager une surenchère
alors aujourd'hui cette rencontre entre
répétez y perdent aux années et vladimir
poutine qu'est ce qu'on doit en
attendaient redonne qui dit ne pas
exclure la signature d'un cessez-le-feu
on a vu les propos préliminaires de
vladimir poutine on vient de les
entendre il a mis la barre très haut il
a dit clairement que les troupes turques
eux se trouvaient là où elle n'avait
rien à faire ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point c'est que il faut
éviter que ça se reproduise pas ce qu'il
y a des morts des deux côtés
et que toute mort est un drame en soi
c'est en gros ce qu'il a dit là dessus
erdogan ne peut pas dire ah mais moi je
reste sur mes positions c'est impossible
il va forcément reculer ils vont se
débrouiller pour donner l'impression que
erdogan sauf la face mais le fait qu'il
soit allé à moscou qu'il est accepté de
venir à moscou
cela prouve déjà que il se trouve en
situation d'infériorité
c'est vrai que c'est la russie
aujourd'hui qui a les cartes en main
dans la région on ne voit pas se
développer un conflit entre la turquie
et la russie
c'est impossible en revanche ce qui va
se passer c'est que on va trouver
ils ont trouvé en tête-à-tête après
s'être copieusement engueulé parce que
je pense que poutine ne va pas garder sa
langue dans sa poche je pense que il va
dire ses quatre vérités envoyé il est en
position de force la indiscutablement
sans support aérien
les turcs ne peuvent pas envoyer des
troupes d'une manière à peu près massive
dans la zone en question c'est
impossible
or l'espace aérien est contrôlé par les
russes
sans compter les batteries anti
aériennes syriennes qui fonctionne et
qui sont relativement efficace en
revanche il y a toujours la possibilité
de duel d'artillerie là contre
l'artillerie turque
il faudrait des frappes aériennes ça
engagerait une certaine escalade
je ne pense pas que après cette entrevue
la turquie ait envie d'engager une
escalade alors vous estimez justement
que les turcs vont reculer en tout cas
ne plus faire la guerre aux syriens dans
cette zone d'idlib
si les arrête de faire la guerre mais
s'il reste dans cette zone on saura donc
dans un statu quo actuellement y aura
les turcs l'autre côté la miss rennes
comment ça va se passer
mais l'armée syrienne va continuer à
progresser et les turcs seront bien
obligés ou de subir des pertes ou de se
retirer dans la zone qui avait été prévu
par les accords de sotchi c'est très
simple on applique le
mémorandum de sotchi et dans ce cas les
turcs eux se mettent dans leur sélection
de la carte sexy donc là ils sont sortis
oui visiblement s'il y a au moins 30
soldats sans doute beaucoup plus qui se
trouve dans un endroit où il ne pas être
ceux qui sont sortis de l'accord de
soutien
pierre laurin merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste écrivain et spécialiste de
la russie
merci à vous